[Applaudissements]
5 degrés est-ce que vous êtes déjà posé
la question parce que c'est un
commentaire réellement 5 degré
c'est quoi c'est un t-shirt à la place
d'un pull
5 degrés ça fait paraître très peu mais
en réalité c'est
il y a 20 millions la moitié de l'Europe
était recouverte par un glacier de 3 km
d'épaisseur des pingouins jouer aux
boules de neige et au sud de la France
et ça rare avec quelques plus grand lac
du monde la seule différence entre ce
monde là et le monde actuel c'est 5
domaines 5 tout petits degrés
maintenant
essayez d'imaginer le monde de demain
avec 5 est devenu supplémentaires on se
rend bien compte que c'est pas juste un
pull en moins qu'on sort pour m'aider à
accepter
c'est un monde qui sera entièrement
chamboulé avec de plus en plus
d'événements dévastateurs comme celui
qui a commisiteur au Canada en 2021
cette ville est devenue tristement
célèbre après avoir connu en pic de
chaleur à 49,6 degrés
49,6° au Canada vous rendez compte on
n'est pas à vous d'avenir pour la route
alors comment on en est arrivé là comme
le dit très bien Jean-Jacques on est
accro aux énergies fossiles c'est comme
une drogue c'est addictif et puis c'est
si facile
on y a tous pris goût elles nous ont
apporté à nos permis d'avoir accès aux
voitures aux vacances pas chères et aux
smartphones
Véronique du sort ce qu'elle nous ont
apporté ce qu'on a de meilleur et
qu'elle va également nous conduire au
pire
alors je sais
je sais pas le truc de la mienne mon
discours je pense que vous l'avez
entendu elle est entendu moi j'espère
parce que réchauffement climatique on a
tous et toutes un pote qui nous rappelle
à longueur de journée qu'il faut qu'on
fasse notre part
actuellement
elle environ de 10 tonnes 10,5 tonnes
pour être exact l'objectif c'est de la
réduire à deux tonnes j'en profite juste
pour rappeler pour ceux qui puissent
encore pour ceux qui pensent encore que
ça me fait des Chinois les Chinois se
disent une tonne comme arrêter les
compter du doigt concrètement comment on
fait pour arriver à deux tonnes de
tonnes il faut arrêter la viande faut
arrêter le poisson faut plus prendre
l'avion faut arrêter de s'acheter des
vêtements et de l'électroménager neuf
je pense qu'on a mis tous ces trucs très
très loin
honnêtement la liste de mes crayons de
traduction elle est très très longue on
la fera pas ce soir je pense que la
perfection est quasiment inatteignable
et les prises de tête elles sont
infinies mais ce qui compte c'est le
chemin
le problème c'est de considérer
uniquement notre consommation et donc
notre empreinte carbone c'est un leurre
aujourd'hui
notre marge de manœuvre elle est très
très faible ses 8 ans
en tant qu'individu on consomme certes
on investit parfois mais surtout on
travaille
est-ce que ça fait vraiment sens
d'arrêter l'avion c'est à côté on bosse
pour une entreprise hyper polluante qui
accélère le réchauffement climatique
notre job c'est 8h par jour 5 jours sur
7 et ça pendant 40 ans
il est là notre plus grand pacte surtout
en tant que je ne diplôme
on a un pouvoir immense de dire non aux
employeurs dont la vision et la
stratégie du monde sont un acronique
moi ce jour j'ai pris conscience de ça
j'ai décidé de démissionner mon CDI au
bout de six mois où j'étais consultante
dans la data je vous rassure je suis pas
en cas isolé 40% des jeunes diplômés qui
tient un job au cours des deux premières
années c'est une histoire qui est assez
banale finalement on a tout et tout un
modèle prédéfini des réussites en fait
d'une école de commerce la voie royale
c'était conseil finance marketing et
maintenant de plus en plus le digital et
adaptable
c'est un monde qui est décorrélé avec
l'urgence écologique et puis
complètement à bout de souffle
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à la fin
de mes études je commence sans tromper
de questions à travailler les entretiens
pour les cabinet de conseils ces
formateurs c'est socialement valorisé
puis c'est très bien rémunéré
à ce moment là j'habite en colocation et
un soir par hasard un pote de mon coloc
s'invite à dîner à la maison c'était son
fameux pote engagé il avait arrêté la
prépa
pour monter une boîte qui permet de
récolter des fonds pour les associations
grâce à la publicité
ça allait même amené à rencontrer Bill
Gates très bien j'étais assez curieuse
de le rencontrer ce soir là on a très
vite évoqué notre conviction est notre
connexion écologique et le modèle de
réussite actuel j'ai bien pris
conscience que le discours bien pensant
que je tenais sur l'écologie il était
pas du tout aligné avec mes ambitions de
carrière professionnelle ce soir là
j'étais pas du tout prête à remettre un
peu cet exemple de réussite
j'ai grandi dans le privilégié je la
reconnais mes parents ont fait des
grandes écoles et ont embrassé les faire
un professionnel qui les attendaient à
la sortie
leur pote également en toute mon
éducation j'ai continué à côtoyer ce
niveau là
pour vous donner une idée j'ai pris une
image qui parle d'elle-même
quand j'étais petit c'est qu'on me
demandait ce que je voulais faire je
vous ai directrice fondamentalement à 8
ans on sait pas ce que ça veut dire
attends
souvent à la maison
on a toutes et toutes des rencontres qui
nous marquent moi ce soir-là il a
planter une graine ce n'est sûrement
d'ailleurs pas rendu compte
au même moment je vais lancer mon
podcast le but c'est de donner la parole
à cette nouvelle génération engagée pour
lui finir principalement les
entrepreneurs commenter des startups qui
cartonnent et qui ont réussi à allier
business et écologique je l'ai prouvé
que oui c'était possible
pourtant quelques mois plus tard je
commence mon premier CD sans grande
conviction je me retourne très vite face
à ma propre contradiction j'ai
conscience de l'urgence écologiques j'ai
conscience que c'est plus grand défi
devrait avoir lieu ma génération et
pourtant je participais pas
quotidiennement
ça crée une réelle frustration et un
sentiment très fort d'impuissance
pourtant ce job avait choisi il pourrait
se trouver un modèle de réussite que
j'avais en tête je peux chez mes gaz
mais fondamentalement j'étais pas
heureuse
on a laps est très court j'ai connu deux
ruptures la rupture de mon CDI mais je
me suis séparée de mon mec pas par
manque de sentiments non il faut
simplement qu'on appelle les mêmes
aspirations et surtout pas la même
conscience écologique au quotidien ça
devient très compliqué l'écologie c'est
un impact sur tout notre alimentation
nos voyages la perception de
l'engagement ou de la réussite je me
retrouvais plus du tout ni dans cette
relation dans ce job j'étais malheureuse
quand j'avais l'impression du front
constamment donc Laurence avec ce que je
connaissais ça à aucun moment j'ai
doutais de ma j'ai doutais de mes
décisions pourtant je suis fan de passer
de mon CDI en couple en freelance et
célibataire mais bon je me suis dit que
mes parents précises allaient avoir un
peu peur être déçu
au contraire de ce que j'étais en pleine
crise je pense qu'au contraire
aujourd'hui sont plutôt fiables c'est
plutôt fiers de voir que j'agis en
cohérence avec ce que je prends des
affaires après ça va peut-être leur
demander qui fonctionne mais
mon podcast ça a été un catalyseur quand
tu rencontres quotidiennement des
personnes qui t'inspirent par leur
courage leur ambition et leur engagement
tu as qu'une envie ces agir à ton tour
moi ce qui m'a le plus marqué c'est le
sentiment très fort de liberté qu'il
dégageait
l'écologie c'est soit aperçu comme une
contrainte on serait contraint par notre
conscience de plus manger de viande de
poisson sinon culpabilise alors c'est
vrai que quand tu as conscience de
l'enjeu est surtout de l'impact que tu
peux avoir c'est très dur de se dire
tant pis je vais manger du saumon et
légumes
et j'entends que certains se disent j'ai
qu'une vie j'ai envie de faire ce que je
veux quand je veux et sans contrainte
c'est tout à fait légitime
mais est-ce que c'est vraiment ça écrit
est-ce que c'est faire souvent nous
semble prendre 50 fois l'avion sans trop
de questions
parce que c'est vraiment ça
moi je suis persuadée du contraire être
libre ça agit en toute connaissance de
cause
c'est sémanciper c'est dans ce fait tu
regardes des autres c'est m'en souffler
de notre conditionnement social
questionner le statu quo
franchement ça implique de s'informer et
surtout d'avoir le courage de s'informer
d'avoir la compréhension la plus fine
possible du monde actuel et surtout de
ce qui nous attend et pour enfin réussir
à succès ses propres contraintes en
accord avec ce qu'on croit nécessaire
on est tous en mesure de comprendre les
gens dans laquelle on est et on est tous
en mesure d'agir l'utopie elle a changé
de compte
on est à l'aube un changement systémique
et qui fait accélérer
on a
les manifeste pareil écologique il a été
signé par 30 000 étudiants et film
rupture a créé un débat de société moi
j'en suis persuadée on est la dernière
génération qu'on va faire changer les
choses
le dernier rapport du chèque vient de
sortir
et concrètement il me reste trois ans
les grands temples question des
entreprises dans lesquelles on va
travailler
on peut plus contenter d'un mot salaire
il faut également exiger un avenir
posez-vous et posez-leur la question de
leur engagement
l'engagement c'est la réduction carbone
l'impact sur la biodiversité ou des
mesures sociétales une entreprise c'est
certes en chiffre d'affaires mais c'est
aussi surtout un agrégat de personnes
si demain ils peuvent pureté ou elle
subissent des démissions en série ils
vont où mettre la clé sous la porte ou
de voir ce réinventer
et je comprends que certains se disent
moi mon ambition c'est transformer
l'entreprise à l'intérieur alors c'est
très bien il faut être réaliste avant
que vous ayez suffisamment de
responsabilités pour un provoquer le
moindre changement il va vous falloir
quoi 5 ans 8 ans 10 ans de carrière on a
plus le temps l'engagement il doit être
maintenant et pas dans les semaines
prochaines années
d'un célèbre une célèbre entreprise
d'énergie fossile française qui
déclarait récemment à l'AFP qu'une de
ses plus grandes craintes ce serait de
plus réussir à attirer les jeunes
talents
aujourd'hui les ingénieurs et je vous le
souhaite ils veulent travailler dans les
énergies renouvelables alors travaillons
un grand groupe oui mais pas pour écrire
n'importe quoi interrogez-vous sur la
finalité de votre job j'en suis sûr vous
êtes doué et plein d'énergie et le
courage de vous engager dans les projets
ambitieux
le réchauffement climatique je vous
l'accorde
c'est pas sexy c'est redondant et
franchement ça anxiogène et je pense
qu'il faut l'aborder comme un challenge
le plus grand challenge de notre époque
moi je trouve ça fascinant tous ces
nouveaux secteurs qui se développent la
rénovation énergétique
la séquestration carbone la mobilité
verte ou les low tech
il y a plein de nouvelles opportunités
et surtout il y a plein de nouvelles
opportunités de carrière qui sont
ambitieuses qui sont bien rémunérées et
qui sont alliés avec le plus grand défi
de notre époque vous imaginez si on y
arrive on sera tellement fier
si je devais être honnête bien sûr qu'il
y a plein de jours je me lève le matin
et je me dis franchement je préférais
pas savoir ma vie elle serait beaucoup
plus simple
[Applaudissements]